mehr als die hälfte der deutschen
unterstützt laut einer neuen umfrage der
forschungsgruppe wahlen die lieferung
schwerer waffen aus deutschland an die
ukraine 56 prozent der befragten finden
die lieferung etwa von panzern richtig
gleichzeitig haben knapp 30 prominente
heute in einem brief an bundeskanzler
olaf scholz genau davor gewarnt die
feministin alice schwarzer war der
sänger reinhard mey der schauspieler
lars eidinger schriftsteller wie martin
walser und juli zeh und auch der
wissenschaftsjournalist ranga yogeshwar
dem russischen präsidenten wladimir
putin dürfe kein motiv für eine
ausweitung des krieges auf die nato
geliefert werden sie warnen vor der
gefahr eines dritten weltkriegs diese
angst haben viele aber ist sie
berechtigt oder fallen wir auf die
angstmacherei auf putins psycho
propaganda rein die der und seine
kriegstreiber seit wochen betreiben
putin führt weltkriegs angst und seine
psychologische kriegsführung sie wirkt
auf die politiker europas der britische
verteidigungsminister ben wallace sagt
heute es würde mich nicht wundern wenn
putin am 9 mai den nazis der ganzen welt
den krieg erklärt die nazis der welt
gemeint sind alle so genannten feinde
russlands
wie weit wird putin gehen wann kommt die
eskalation noch hat er keine rakete auf
nato territorium oder den rest der welt
abgefeuert aber er sagt die kommt wenn
ihr mich weiter provoziert
wenn irgendwer von außerhalb sich in die
laufenden ereignisse einmischt und so
eine strategische gefahr für uns schafft
muss er mit einer blitzschnellen antwort
rechnen wir haben dafür alle instrumente
und wir werden nicht plan hier werden
sie anwenden wenn es nötig ist und ich
will dass alle das wissen die russische
propaganda maschine sie läuft immer
wieder schüren russische
regierungsvertreter angst muss die
risiken sind in der tat sehr sehr ernst
es wäre überhaupt nicht wünschenswert
wenn diese risiken noch künstlich
aufgeblasen würden und es genügend leute
die das gerne tun würden die gefahr ist
ernst sie ist real man darf sie nicht
unterschätzen und
der russische ex präsident mit wwf warnt
nachdem der bundestag die lieferung
schwerer waffen für die ukraine
beschließt es wird traurig enden die
angst vor der nächsten eskalation dieses
grausamen krieg sie wächst und genau das
so scheint es will putin
ja in der tat viele menschen machen sich
sorgen bei uns im studio ist bild
chefreporter peter tiede der
viele wochen in russland und in moskau
war während dieses krieges peter ich
habe es gesagt meine mutter
beispielsweise hat sehr große angst wenn
sie das alles hört dritter weltkrieg bis
82 hat krieg schon miterlebt ist diese
angst berechtigt nein es ist nicht
berechtigt die ist aber gewollt und dies
gewollt durch den kreml die wird erzeugt
das nennt sich ich habe darüber mit
diversen experten geredet und unter
anderem alexander graf lambsdorff von
der fdp der verweist darauf dass es in
der alten sowjetischen und russischen
militärdoktrin den begriff der reflex
kontrolle gab es gibt für jedes land
quasi ein so eine art psychogramm im
kreml für die psychologische
kriegsführung also wovor haben die leute
angst in deutschland ist bekannt die
deutschen haben angst vor einer rohstoff
sperre und vor dem atomkrieg die
baltischen staaten haben angst vor einem
einmarsch der russen die sind ja schon
einmal bist besetzt war nämlich vor dem
auto zum beginn des ersten weltkrieges
sind die besetzt worden von der
damaligen sowjetunion
die usa haben natürlich angst vor einem
nuklear schlag auf washington oder
florida auch diesen klavier auf dieser
tastatur spielt der kreml seit siebzig
achtzig jahren immer mit derselben mit
den selben sachen das ist inzwischen
fast und radiert das ist angekommen in
der deutschen seele um gottes willen der
russe dreht in alle drittens um gottes
willen heraus gekommen um gottes willen
der atomschlag kommt die angst ist da
dies immer gespürt worden und sie wird
immer wieder dann wenn man es braucht
benutzt warum macht wladimir putin dass
er hat kein sieg vorzuweisen die der
schnelle enthauptungsschlag in diesem
krieg ist nicht gelungen jetzt steht er
neunter mai an der neunte mal wir haben
bilder gilt gesehen von den großen
paraden die deutschen meinen mir immer
das immer am 9 mai dem tag des sieges
über hitler über das über
hitler-deutschland die separaten schon
in der sowjetunion stattgefunden haben
schon immer stattgefunden haben das
stimmt nicht die wand immer am ersten
mai putin hat die neu aufgeladen
wirklich zum heiligen tag im putin reich
selbst die kirche die für die
streitkräfte gebaut wird das vor den
toren moskaus das ist eingraviert 19.45
jedes maß in dieser kirche hat mit dem
zweiten weltkrieg zu tun jetzt ist
dieser neunter und am 9 mai muss
irgendetwas präsentieren seinem volk
einen sieg hatte nicht mario pohl nicht
angenommen kiew nicht eingenommen und
deshalb nicht eingenommen den sonnen was
immer noch nicht eingenommen also was
macht er er geht in die propaganda er
führt im westen angst er macht
propaganda im eigenen land da wird ein
riesengroßer propaganda show vorbereitet
und er wird natürlich das was wir jetzt
gemacht hat als der un-generalsekretär
jetzt einen kia fleet eine rakete ein
vielmehr hat er nicht hat nicht 100 er
hat nicht 200 die 500er kann die steht
nicht in schutt und asche legen er
schickt aber ganz gezielt einzelne
schlägereien und damit führt er ängste
im westen um in seinem eigenen land zu
demonstrieren demonstrieren zu können
guckt mal die haben angst vor uns wer so
wer so agiert der hat selbst ein
fernseher gehört das wird schlimm enden
ja die frage ist nur für wen also nicht
für uns gerade kabel unter gefallen
nichts passiert hier im studio peter du
hast sehr lange für uns berichtet hat
erlebt wie die menschen dort reagiert
haben in russland selber wir haben immer
gehört die stehen hinter putin zum einen
weil sie einen starken führer auch haben
wollen weil sie davon überzeugt sind
dass so ein großes reich wie russland
nur von am starken führer
zusammengehalten werden kann
andererseits wissen wir dass sie auch
nur die propaganda bekommen alle medien
sind kontrolliert glaubst du dass nach
dieser zeit nach über zwei monaten
mittlerweile die russen die russen auch
mitbekommen haben das ist nicht so
richtig läuft wie putin eigentlich
behauptet und das vielleicht auch diese
unterstützung bröckelt die unterstützung
bröckelt nicht ebenfalls nicht
nennenswert aber immer wenn im volk so
eine ahnung aufkommt menschen dauert
gern dauert ganz schön lang fast feiern
wir eigentlich jetzt am 9 mai dann setzt
die propaganda ein dann dreht man zum
beispiel polen den gashahn ab und in
deutschland und sofort ein riesen des
gesamten gottes willen dann sind wir
dran sind wir die nächsten jetzt müssen
wir schritt zurück gehen und dann gucken
wir mal hin das kommt natürlich in
russland wunderbar an rudi jetzt haben
die angst guck mal die brauchen unser
gas und alles was wir berichten alles
was an angst im westen produziert wird
oder aufgeschrieben wird kommt in der
russischen propaganda zehnfach verstärkt
wieder hin wird den russen dargereicht
gucken wir mal ganz genau in polen hat
ohnehin den ausstieg aus russischem gas
geplant und angekündigt jetzt dreht man
polen dem start vor deutschland den
gashahn hans wir hängen alle anderen an
derselben leitung damit wird im sinne
dieser reflex kontrolle bei uns gezielt
angst geschürt diese angst wie gesagt
wird von der propaganda wieder wieder
hin transportiert und wenn man durch
russland fährt vielleicht in den
großstädten aber du bist in sibirien
irgendwo abgelegen selbst an dem
rostigen letzten lager für den man gar
keine scheiben hinten ein haus fenster
eingebaut hat damit das auto noch nie zu
es klebt der aufkleber nach berlin nach
berlin das ist das was unter putin
wirklich zum zum heiligen gemacht von
ist also der gründungsmythos für
russland ist der sieg über über
deutschland über nazi deutschland da
wird inzwischen auch so getan als habe
russland das ganz allein geschafft und
damit wird der stolz erzeugt und dann
sind die russen bereit auf alles zu
verzichten
auch zugaben hauptsache man ist der
einsame kämpfer gegen die nazis in der
ganzen welt in ordnung von peter tiede
vielen dank dafür peter